we could argue the practical appeal of
the snow Pecos uki lantern but we mostly
want it because it's so easy on the eyes
you can use it as a tabletop light but
it really shines outdoors the silicone
rubber Lantern shade diffuses glare
it'll last for 80 hours on just four
doublea's or if you want to let up the
whole campsite in the last eight hours
at the highest intensity don't get us
started on the lantern - charming candle
mode in which the LED light flickers
like a small fire in response to sound
or wind it's just like camping faux
candle novelty aside it's just an
attractive functional package long
lasting light when you're in the middle
of nowhere as bright or as dim as you
want